This 3D Printed tracheal implant saved this
baby's life.
And some cockroaches have evolved to avoid
poison traps that use sugary bait.
So yeah.
Vsauce!
Kevin here - this is Mind Blow
This robot tells you if you have bad breath.
Developed by CrazyLabo and the Kitakyushu
National College of Technology the humanoid
responds to the smell of your breath with
phrases like "it smells like citrus" - and
it works by using gas sensors that create
a chemical footprint which can be matched
to specific odors.
There's also a robot dog that will smell your
feet.
While these are novel applications - they
have more serious ones for this technology
down the road in medical fields.
Cosmologists believe they've found the first
hard evidence of multiple universes.
Data from the Plank Satellite of cosmic radiation
shows large cold spots where according to
our understanding of physics shouldn't exist.
Theoretical Physicist Dr. Mersini-Houghton
believes the anomalies are caused by other
universes pulling on our universe as it formed
during the Big Bang and while many scientists
are skeptical of other universes these unexplained
features of the map will at the least require
new physics to be understood according to
the European Space Agency.
Tracking Point has developed a interface similar
to a fighter jet display for their precision
guided firearms.
It not only displays information like range,
wind speed and shot angle but allows the user
to lock onto the target with a desired impact
point.
Critics say it takes the fair chase principle
away from hunting and other wonder if this
technology should be in the hands of civilians
and they range in price from 17 to $22,000.
Newly discovered mini-spider from china
Antiquity music has developed the Wheelharp
a chamber string orchestra keyboard.
It allows you to play 61 bowed strings - there
are currently four prototypes and they're
crowd funding the project right now - here's
what it sounds like...
Seal is a wearable swim monitoring system
that warns parents and lifeguards if someone
is drowning.
The neck band has four levels of alert that
can be set depending on the experience of
the swimmer and when in danger it sends a
warning signal or full alarm to the monitoring
hub.
Find the link below for more...
Bare Conductive has created electrically conductive
paint.
It allows you to apply paints to walls and
other surfaces that enable a kind of liquid
wiring.
It's non-toxic and can be used for simple
things like turn on lights or creating interactive
art or posters.
Hot.
Pink.
Slug.
Mobile eye visions technologies is developing
a camera-only autonomous driving system that
uses just a few hundred dollars worth of materials.
While not as advanced as the self-driving
google car it uses technology currently seen
in Volvos that predict and react to pedestrians
and cyclists and they have plans to introduce
more advanced systems by 2016.
Finally, Sonic Water is a cymatics installation
visualizing sound and vibration with the music
of Kymat...
I'm gonna leave you with a 3D printed robot
that plays pool and as always - thanks for
watching.